e
e e
thank you all for being here today I'm
not used to sitting in this
chair um so we are coming together for
the subcommittee on House Bill
553 um we want to respect all the work
that was done by Senator Carson and her
committee over last summer and fall
along with a lot of our Advocates and we
do think that they did a very thorough
job but some questions some worries have
come up so we just want to make sure
that we have all of those kind of
fleshed out so that that way people can
understand where it's coming from how
this law would impact um or how this
change in 169c would actually impact um
the state and families in the state I
also want to start out by saying that on
House Bill 5 53 this is not a um a
punishment thing or anything this is
literally the definitions of child abuse
and neglect and the rebuttable
presumption of harm and abuse and
neglect case so this is really the
foundation of how we then build other
bills as far as what we do with this
information but for us this would be a
definition of what abuse is so I will um
leave it to any of the committee members
if you have a subject you'd like to
bring up first I know that we have had
quite a few um
questions yes
representative eimon thank you madam
chair uh there was a question of the
constitutionality of this bill uh I
checked the Constitution and in my
opinion there is
no um data say showing that this is
unconstitutional and further I went into
the system and there are a multitude of
cases one being uh Troxel V Troxel where
the Supreme Court felt
that uh this particular Bill uh and the
definitions of which don't seem to fit
the criteria for being non uh
unconstitutional either and I just
wanted to set that tone before we move
on with this important work thank you I
appreciate it there has been a lot of
question on that and um certainly I
think that is once again when we have
extensions of this bill what we do as
far as um quote unquote punishments or
actions and stuff that is not not a part
of the definitions of this does anybody
else have a concern that they'd like to
bring up thank you for your work on
that are any concerns that you've heard
so one of the things that we did uh we
had some testimony on was actually our
trauma informed language um when it
comes to somebody who has a substance
abuse disorder
and so I did actually look at trauma
informed language so here's what we what
we have um and then uh I I have supplied
this to the office of child advocate um
so the more trauma informed language and
then why the changes so we can take a
look at that that could be a possible
amendment I also do want to um bring to
light that I think a lot of the concerns
that we had before were based on how 553
came out of OSS which was not the
intended way that it came out so we did
have that
um uh the amendment yeah which what is
that
number uh yeah the amendment
is4 114 Zer yeah 114 so anyway and that
replaces that language back to what the
uh study committee had and that we
refined last fall y so if everybody
wants to look at the trauma in form
language does anybody in the audience
want to see what the trauma and form
language is and
why got some extra
copies and this is just around concerns
of um mothers who have substance abuse
uh disorder and their child is born does
this you know flag them to have their
children removed immediately it does not
it just we understand that children who
are born uh with substances have
tendency to have certain complications
and we want to make sure that that's um
known that that's not um best practice
for
children everybody agree with
that
okay so does someone want to get an
amendment to so that language yes would
you guys like to vote on that language
or or do we have to vote what do we well
I I or we just have to do an amendment
yeah so I agree that we need to do that
but I think there may be further changes
uh to the current Amendment before we
um we send to any right uh language to
OS and I'd like it to be one um I
personally would like it to be one clean
Amendment so I absolutely agree that
this should go into the amendment but we
not um send anything to OS and until
we're done I agree and I don't we
haven't voted on the other amendment
that we brought in so we could actually
redo and have one one seamless Amendment
correct okay so we can do that
okay
absolutely okay so well she has uh do
you want me to wait to continue at all
right ahead okay so I think one of the
larger questions that we had and this
was on and I know there's some people
here that can testify who are doing
groundwork on this particular thing is
the emotional abuse side of it and
whether or not somebody could let's say
get in trouble for grounding their child
for you know not having their car or say
the child comes out as um as gay or
something and then that's disagreed upon
would that be you know grounds for a
child for being abused would and my
understanding has always been that a
disagreement is a disagreement it's how
far you take it that whether or not it
takes it do we have somebody in the
audience that has done ground workor
recently or can talk to us about what
DCF would if there would be an
intervention or what would happen in
that
case good morning Jen Ross deputy
director DCF thank
you can you ask your question again
representative Greg yes so one of the
concerns that we had is basically on the
emotional abuse side and what that
entails like whether or not a parent
disagreeing with the child's gender or a
parent disagreeing about whether or not
a child has certain friends or how that
impacts how that would fall into that
would that be a concern with the way
that the language is now written on 553
having emotional and psychological abuse
or what if that was called in let's say
what what you would look at for that um
it would not make any changes to what we
would currently do um when we think
about psychological abuse and when we
are looking at the information that's
being reported whether to screen in or
screen out we're looking at um a couple
of different things one is the nature of
the um the allegation we're looking at
um is it something that is likely to
cause or the child is likely to suffer
serious psychological emotional harm as
a result of the parents behaviors their
actions are inactions um and we're
looking at um things such as pers
persistent and severe uh like ridiculing
uh terrorizing bullying isolating we're
looking at um ongoing
oh yeah certainly
y so this is right from our um our own
policy so psychological abuse is defined
as reports where a child suffers or is
likely to suffer
psychological emotional harm as a result
of Parental
behaviors it considers both the
caregiver's actions and
inactions as well as the impact to the
child so actions that are reasonably
expected to produce significant adverse
impact on a child's emotional well-being
could be examples like persistent and
severe ridiculing terrorizing bullying
or isolating of a
child it could be threatening specific
physical harm to themselves a family
member or the pets persistent
non-specific threats of self harm
uh or care caregiver overdose in front
of the child so those are sort of what
we're thinking of when we're looking at
psychological emotional abuse
yes I see that you're reading that uh
policy um is it possible for that to be
forwarded to us in some way yep yeah I I
can't I'm sorry and and this is so
crucial I don't want to miss anything
yes it truly is crucial I believe to the
bill yes thank you and then we're
looking at what is the impact to the
child um does the child have ongoing um
indicators of emotional disturbance or
emotional abuse which would be bed
weding um anger issues psychological
emotional concerns um depression anxiety
severe withdrawal um extrem or
persistence Behavior or running away or
self harming and so really it's the
twofold it's what is the action or
action of the caregiver and then what is
the result of that action or in action
to the child um and so certainly I think
when you're being asked about whether or
not taking away car keys or uh grounding
um a child or taking away their cell
phone is what we would consider to be
that prudent parenting you're doing it
for a reason of concern uh either
they're contacting you know someone that
they shouldn't be contacting to
representative Greg's um example uh or
you're trying to prevent them from
harming themselves or harming others
That's The Prudent parenting that we one
would expect a parent would do to take
those actions um if there was
concern thank you thank you for taking
my question there has been uh there have
have been statements bantered about that
people are afraid to um be on board with
this bill because they're afraid that
parents will say go clean your room and
don't come out of your room till it's
cleaned up that that would be considered
parental abuse can you speak a little
bit about that thank
you yeah exactly so if we were to
receive a call on that it would not be
something that would be screened in
because again it's prudent parenting a
parent exercising their right to ask
their child to go clean their room and
don't come out until it's clean again
what we would be looking for is some
more of those extreme um actions of a
parent where they're perhaps locking
their child in their room for days until
the room is cleaned or something like
that so a simple request by parent for a
child to go do something is not in of
itself emotional abuse or neglect
um thank you for being here thanks for
taking my question so I know that one of
the concerns that people are having are
um what if a parent denies gender
affirming care to their child because
they don't believe that that
is necessary believes they're too young
believes
anything um how are we going to protect
those parents because this is going to
be a problem to get this
passed so if a parent is again acting
within their right as a parent and it's
prudent parenting that is a I think for
me it's a little bit more of a difficult
um what if um to say that there'd be one
thing or another I think we would have
to look at the whole picture of that um
so what is the outcome of that for the
young person um and are they you know
what is the conversation that the parent
is having with the young person around
the gender affirming care or their they
their disagreement with that action for
their youth um we would want to know um
how is that impacting the youth um and
or the child themselves it's it's a hard
question to answer either way um I think
there's a lot of things what we would be
looking at again is that's a parent's
right to exercise um that particular
right for themselves and their youth um
but I get the bigger picture like is it
causing the youth severe um emotional
discomfort yeah I don't know Susan if
you want to help me with the legal so
in in that so if you got a call that
would not be screened
out well so we got a call and it was
simply that um they were not allowing
their their child to do that no it would
probably be screened out um I don't know
if probably is a strong enough I don't
know that's a strong enough word I I I
have I I'm concerned yeah so again it we
we would be looking at if a child had
diabetes and needed Medical Care and the
parent was um withholding that Medical
Care from their child that would and and
that's a life um altering you know a a
life-threatening um disability we that
would be a report in of neglect from the
parent um for in their inability to
provide their child the correct or
needed Medical Care um affirming um care
is not an in my opinion is not a
necessary medical care for the child
that they would need so a parent would
have the right to not um con consent to
that care for their
child and it wouldn't be screened in
under neglect so what we're looking for
is what is the outcome to the child so
that wouldn't necessarily be neglect for
the child because it's not a medical
necess a necessary medical care for them
is it more how it's so this is not in
itself denying the gender care would not
be an issue it's how the parent handles
it after that so it's one thing to tell
your kid no I disagree it's another
thing to start getting you know verbally
emotionally maybe physically abusive
about how you how you have that
conversation and that's why it might
lead to something besides screening it
out is that kind of what you're saying
yes yeah yes so it is it it depends on
how the parent then goes about handling
it and it depends on what's happening
for the Youth um and so if because the
parent and youth have a disagreement
with you know what's to happen the youth
wants the gender affirming care the
parent doesn't want it the youth then
becomes angry upset suicidal and needs
additional mental health care as a
result of that we would expect the
parent to meet the needs of that
additional mental health care and if
they're not doing that then that could
potentially be neglect um or like you
said representative Greg the other side
is how is the parent handling um that
request of their youth if they disagree
with that um and so then do they start
calling them names or are they um you
know prohibiting them from let's say
they want to wear certain clothes and it
becomes a greater issue where the parent
is now
persistently um you know negatively
communicating with their child about
their wishes or their wants and it
becomes then a a bigger
issue
okay thank you representative CG thank
you for taking my question um do you
have um an imp policy for screeners to
have the same um uh approach to this um
topic that you
do we do yes we do have policy for
screening um all of our screeners look
at the policy to determine what is the
information they're receiving uh what
where does it fall within our policy
pertaining to neglect or abuse um and
then they start to weed out the
specifics um and then they look at you
know this then this then this so there
is some consistent decision making is it
in there specifically around uh gender
affirming care no we don't have anything
specific to
that can I follow up oh yeah would you
be able to do
that I'm uncertain if we would want to
start breaking out different types of
needs that families have you know we
keep it broad for a reason and so if we
were to add gender affirming care would
we then have to add uh something else or
in addition to gender affirming care
that could become a challenge for
families to navigate
through I I know that's an important
topic for for a lot of people and I do
understand and once again I I think when
we're looking at definitions of
emotional it's not just disagreeing with
the child it's really like where you
take that that's what emotional and
psycholog I think that's really the kind
of Crux of the entire thing that it's
not about saying gosh I mean we're
talking about gender affirming care even
though yes that's very impactful we talk
also talk about piercing ears or you
know other things that kids religion y
you know so I see I see the how hard
that would be to start separating things
out to specify for each each individual
thing certainly religion is a big topic
one that I even had with my own children
um where we differ and that's part of
them becoming you know who we who we um
are raising so thank you for that does
anybody else have any questions for her
on
that um okay did you have okay did you
have something legally that you wanted
to talk about Susan with that or
okay come on up I see her yes I
know good morning thank you for having
me Susan larby General Council for DCF
again I just want to reiterate that over
the last decades the legislature all of
us have been doing a lot of work based
on what we've learned about being trauma
informed and back in 2021 I think I
mentioned as a previous hearing back in
2021 uh the legislature added house bill
1573 to the statute which finally
defined psychological M
treatment and as deputy director Ross
just pointed to our policy that policy
and procedure was written in response to
finally defining psychological Mal
treatment which we all Society know that
that is the most common form of abuse
and neglect in our country probably the
world if you look at statistics and so
back in 2021 they uh the legislature you
all added psychologic melt treatment
finallys the definitions that
psychological melt treatment means
pervasive and emotionally abusive
Behavior which shall include but not be
limited to patterns of threatening
berating or demeaning behavior and
representative Greg as you mentioned
it's not necessarily the the reason why
they are berating the child or
belittling the child it's the it's the
belittling and the and
the berading and the patterns of
threatening behavior that's the neglect
of a
child I hope that makes sense and again
the context of it all so there is really
no change to the definitions of neglect
right the definition of neglect that you
have a parent who is or child sorry a
neglected child who is without the
proper parental care or control Ed
education is required by law or other
care control and there is that serious
risk of impairment that harm and we're
just fine-tuning what is that harm
that's really hard to Define it's really
it's very nebulous um and what has been
done over the course of many many months
and now years is relooking at these
definitions as they are so the average
person when they're reading the statue
understand what it means because serious
impairment risk of serious impairment
that's a mouthful um it then points you
to another section of the statute saying
okay let's define serious impairment
serious impairment means a substantial
weakening or diminishment of a child's
emotional physical or mental health or
of a child's safety and well-being again
that's already in the statute it's just
very hard to understand so again what
was what's being done here and
throughout many efforts and a
collaborative effort is to make it more
user friendly that the average reader is
going to read this statue and understand
what's expected of our community when it
comes to reporting AB suspicous of abuse
and
neglect thank you what statute are you
referring sure I'm I'm looking at the
definition section 169
C3 and for the definition of
psychological melt treatment and the
definitions are are in um alphabetical
order so we are up
to yes 25A I know I had to do my Roman
numeral
conversion that's what I thought I I
appreciate it I just want to be sure
that my notes are sure thank you okay
thank
you go ahead representative Greg I
received an email from representative
marel okay concerning a concise analysis
of the proposed amendment I'd like to
pass it out I haven't
um I have enough if anybody in the
audience would like to see it I have um
um a copy that I can share and we'll
just take a minute to look this over I I
think he makes some good points
um
e e
can can you tell me the qualifications
for the
cpsws and um as far as it pertains to
psychological abuse um
also um
yeah I just want to know how they're
trained in in that that appears to be
one of
um attorney
maral's
concerns and trust me I have a daughter
who's a social workers I already know
the answer but go
ahead good morning Jen Ross deputy
director um so to your question of the
qualifications of a cpsw um we they're
Broad uh we can take anyone with uh an
education in human services social work
uh psychology education we look for um a
background in working with children
youth and families um to bring that work
into ours um but we certainly will you
know we will work with anyone who has
that education component uh even if they
lack an extensive history uh they then
go through uh what we call a Core
Academy which is a 12we um educational
component for our staff um that really
goes over our policies procedural work
with families engaging families um and
understanding sort of what it is to be a
cpsw and what does that role look like
there's a component of going through the
law and the statute with them um there's
a component of uh going through
investigations and casework with
families and how to engage them so we
really focus on the engagement with
families to understand what is the
challenges that brought your family to
our attention and then how can we work
together so there isn't a specific Focus
if you will on psychological or
emotional well-being um it's really
looking at the family as the whole scope
we do have staff attorneys that we then
work with to determine what is the
information that I've collected these
are the concerns and what fits the scope
of the law or doesn't fit the scope of
the law and supervision you know and so
it's it's really a team approach to the
information that we're Gathering and
then what does that mean in terms of how
we might be become involved or not
become involved or what is the family
need in addition to that for referrals
or
resources I don't know that answers your
question so um I guess
my
uh what how do I want to phrase
this um so you if if it is a case of um
psychological abuse you have the ability
to um offer resources to these families
especially for say a psychiatrist or a
counselor or things like that correct
yes okay thank you
yep I don't know if any of who would be
the right person to answer this question
but in looking at um representative
markel's uh suggestions and stuff this
looks more like to me the process that
would be litigated after DC has initial
findings where these the bill we're
talking about is actually just
definitions so I'm actually concerned
that he's taking it that bit farther
this is not about definitions what I see
unless I'm understanding this
wrong structuring a policy procedures
turn your mic on it's it's not
structuring policies or procedures it's
strictly definitions as a guideline MH
so I I too don't feel that this is this
stuff is necessary to change anything in
here yeah I think he makes points for
after the fact but not about this
particular yes let sasio you think she's
got
input oh I was goingon to say to your
point ex exactly representative Greg
that this is information that we would
do um post filing or even before filing
if we were working with a family on an a
voluntary basis is really um allowing
for these assessments to occur to help
us have a better understanding of what
are the needs of the child the youth or
the family and then what are the
appropriate referrals for them so
exactly this would be our case work
after filing or when we open a case to
um work with a
family hi Lista massio associate child
advocate um and I we're sharing all one
copy here but um I just want wanted to
reiterate too that um the basis of this
bill it did come before the legislature
last session in tandem with s SP
4177 which was written very specifically
around placement preferences and this
bill the the sort of purpose section and
4177 really focuses on the fact that
preserving the unity of the family is
the primary purpose maintain maining the
family Unity so this is not meant to
take children away from parents which
417 says very clearly that's already
been signed into law in this purpose
section very clearly again there's even
a change in language here that says
instead of determining the best interest
of the child it is determined already
that the best interest is to remain with
family um so again I think you all keep
hitting on on the the point here that
these are the definitions
that allow the agency to get involved to
provide services to help that family
maintain their integrity um one of the
precursors too was that there were times
though where the agency was trying to
get involved had filed a petition even
for an inhome case which means the
family children not get removed and the
courts were interpreting neglect
interpreting serious impairment in a way
that was leading to results that babies
with nine broken bones were getting sent
right back to caregivers without any
services or safety plans in place so it
was sort of that Gap that was trying to
be filled and continues trying to be
filled that the goal is not to take a
bunch of children away from parents who
want to make them clean their rooms it
really was filling these specific gaps
um that the agency was seeing so I just
wanted to kind of Jen's doing a great
job I just want to bring that up
again thank you um I I just want to let
you know that at the last DCF meeting uh
of which I'm on the
board this is exactly what I was talking
about is the where is and I ask the
question where is the gap uh what does
the legislature need to do to fill that
Gap so that the job can be done well and
and and I think that's what you're just
pointing out to us and I appreciate that
and that's why we worked so closely this
fall we had eight sessions most of them
two hours long in front of Senator
Carson Senator Whitley representative
mcmah was there as well and
representative Robert harb talking
through every word in here every
Amendment what the purpose was what the
outcome would be and really thoughtfully
collaborating um of you know what would
be the impact of changing this word that
word and and as attorney larby said some
of these changes were made and policies
have been put into place but the court
is still not quite reading it the same
way particularly I think the addition of
the definition of trauma informed was
super helpful and that was at the
request of Senator Carson and
representative McMahon we all say that
all the time like we know what it means
but again I think attorney lby is
correct that a lot of the nuances here
are not a change but make it a lot more
transparent for parents to know what
truly is abuse or
neglect so I think
to talk a little bit about um
representative maral's email I think
what he's trying to do
is understand what the bill and the
amendment say and then try to educate us
on what would happen if it goes to
court not that
not that we need to change everything in
the bill but he's I think that's where
his brain's going so I agree with you
that this is going to be the aftermath
yeah well this yeah and I I think that I
appreciate that he's of of that mind and
that we have him on our committee now to
kind of help us work through that stuff
but what that comes you don't have that
kind of you know when we go through the
steps of legislation as far as I
understand I'm still fairly
but is that when we have the definitions
this is not this is literally the root
of this of protecting kids and what he's
talking about is something that builds
on after so maybe there's something in
legislation that comes from this but
this at least defines it and that's my
understanding so I think he's got a
valid point but I just don't think it
belongs in here then all of a sudden
it's not just definitions right and I I
think too for just from what I've
skimmed it would be several steps like
attorney larby said when the law changed
in 2021 legislature did a definition it
was two sentences long the division then
works on creating new policies new
standard operating procedures that then
goes into their core training it goes
into attorney training so I think you're
right that this definitions is the first
step and then you need to let it play
out a bit let the division do their work
the OCA does have oversight we work with
them very closely on developing policies
um and you'd have to let it play out
again and see like the policies and
trainings that happened
right if I may so I so what
I'm getting from this is this is just
providing clar Clarity and transparency
especially for parents too right there's
nothing in here that says we're taking
your children this is just providing
transparency and Clarity of the
definitions that are B really already
being put to
work um and so I I don't other than the
the changes that with the
trauma um language trauma informed
language I don't
see any problems with this bill I think
it was it was worked on intensely I
think that you know anything that was
not appropriate to be put in here I
trust was not I know senator
Carson and so that's that's where I am
with this I I think that this is with as
amended
is can only help parents in my
opinion thank you and thank you for
taking my
question should this bill become law do
you foresee any
significant increases in the amount of
cases that will uh happen or this is
going this is not going to increase and
it's just defining and and Def better
defining what is already in
practice thank you thank you for the
question I I don't see it as increasing
cases for the division um like um OCA
masio suggested is that it's just some
additional Clarity for um the division
uh and I think additional Clarity for
the courts I think it will help us
protect um a certain population of
children um who I think we have
struggled to protect those being the
youngest with those injuries that have
um been a challenge we've worked
together with the OCA to have
discussions about those which I think
was some of the precipitous to prompt
this this legislation um I it it does
allow us to to work with families in the
way we already are um and so I don't
necessarily see it as a way for us to
become further court involved with
families
um thank you that's what I thought too I
wanted it on the record because I think
that there are people who are very
concerned about that so I just wanted to
to have that and and we worked very hard
to um bring this forward in a way that
wasn't an expansion so much as a
clarification I believe uh the division
has said throughout that there was no
fiscal notice as well um we did actually
take out a section during that fall
working Section on institutional child
abuse um because the implementation of
it would have been challenging it may
have created more cases it it was a
little bit unclear so we were very
mindful about that through that whole
working process in the
fall do you know how many states have
language similar to this with the
emotional in there I do not know the
number of states but I can tell you when
the OCA was working on this language
originally which was in the fall of
20123 um we had done sort of a survey of
a number of other states on a a number
of different sections um looking at
Colorado Connecticut
um New Jersey maybe there was like five
or six that we were looking at to try
and really hone in on on the right
terminology um and most of those I think
all of those ones were using emotional
they had sort of a different combination
so we sort of landed on the combination
that made the most sense um but
certainly it was ours was much narrower
than many others at this point because
ours was drafted 45 years ago and had
not had sort of a a large expansion of
of
terminology and we hear about this more
and more and I think just for the record
it's important to understand why is it
important to include emotional when
we're talking about these
definitions it's important because
emotional abuse um tends it's it's not
when we investigate or have uh an
involvement with a family it's sometimes
not just one type of abuse or neglect
that we see um that we know emotional
abuse uh happens far more frequently and
can be just as traumatic for a child to
experience um and the old legislation um
was prohibitive of our ability to be
able to recognize emotional and
psychological abuse of children um we
had to
have Specialists to come in and testify
to the fact that that was happening uh
this does allow us an ability to um be
more involved with families when they're
struggling with um you know meeting
their needs of their kids in a healthy
way um that's not you know emotionally
or physically or or um damaging to their
well-being so I think it's important to
have the psychological Mal treatment
component we know it's it's pretty
damaging to
kids is there anyone way that you can
find out that for us how many states
other states involve the emotional and
psychological abuse in their definitions
I actually have that um at home so I
can't tell
you you okay with jodies I'm okay
whoever wants to do the research
chair yes
um don't we want to um check out um
representative Nelson's research and
look at what we have here as a
definition for the emotional abuse um
versus in other states versus what
happens in other states um tried and
true methods or whatever I I just think
it really emotional abuse is so
difficult to Define um I I read um and
I'm I'll bet people out here have heard
about the books I've read David pelzer's
books um I I don't know if you've ever
read them it's
a powerful powerful powerful if
you uh if you want a good
cry but he his first book was a child
called
it um
they are absolutely
horrifying
um and I don't mind telling you that uh
I am a
survivor um I had one brother called a
bundle of love and myself my younger
brother and my sister were called
Meatheads I get it I get how somebody
would say because of uh there were there
was a series on TV about um a very nasty
man and he called his son-in-law
Meathead and people thought it was funny
it's
not it's just not so I I think it's
important for us to get that component
of this bill
right uh it's very difficult for a child
to come forward and
say how it hurts their hearts and and
I've said this a million times uh on my
refrigerator I always posted when I was
raising my kids Sticks and Stones can
break your bones but words can break
your heart we can put casts on broken
bones and not to minimize that and I'm
not minimizing the the physical abuse at
all we can put Band-Aids we can put
stitches we can heal bones but we we
forget about healing the heart and I
think that's one of the most important
components of this bill is
how do we help parents understand what
words do to
children I appreciate you sharing that
representative deimon I actually have a
resource that I meant to send to you
this morning and I forgot I'll will send
it to you as soon as I get back to my
office I actually attended a really
wonderful training um for the new
children's attorneys you all passed SB
463 last year um about Aces the adverse
childhood experiences so that study
originally B dates back all the way to
the early 90s it not controversial in
any way well accepted science there were
definitions of emotional abuse and
emotional neglect in that original study
so I have a slide deck to share with you
all um that I think really does lay that
Foundation it's not new it is very old
um it just hasn't correct so um but I
think it would be really helpful because
it really splits out sort of those
adverse childhood experiences and the
different typ types of abuse and neglect
which includes very specifically
emotional gives some examples so I I
think it'd be helpful for you all and
also just in talking to your colleagues
um so I will share that and I apologize
I it was on my list of things to do this
morning it's a Monday yes it sure is now
that we are going to have one more um
subcommittee meeting I think after this
in a couple week actually it's G to end
up in a few weeks because we have that
week off so um anyway we will have
another one so we can talk more about
that does anybody else have concerns for
today that they'd like to flush out go
ahead just some feedback that I've heard
is that people are concerned about um
specifically what the definition is of
that and they're really stuck on the if
I send my kid to the their room are they
going to call um dcyf so um that is one
thing that I wanted to bring up here
today yeah and I think that's going to
be important for us to have those
conversations because I there is a sense
and you get that any anytime we talk
about the definitions of child abuse and
we we start talking about the neglect
people get worried because of what
happens after that um we did have in all
um uh openness we had you know a couple
different groups wanting exceptions like
except and we heard that the other day
you know that this is ex abuse except
for when but ultimately this is about
the definitions of child abuse period
what happens after that is very very
different this gives no more right for
people to take their kids away as a
matter of fact this actually has
language in here that strengthens as as
um um I want to call you just Lisa as
Lissa masio from yeah the uh the OCA has
said but we do know and it is in law in
Statute in this state that we think the
family is the best place so that's
really the security blanket on this for
families this is about defining it so
that we can get definitions so people
that maybe have patterns set up from
their own how they were raised or
whatever we can you know they can step
in and say so that's not that's not the
best practice anymore we understand that
this is not great and that's my
understanding is that for you guys
correct
okay so I just want to um be reassured
you're going to send us the the the list
that's going to be very helpful I will
yes yep
did you have something that you wanted
to talk about
okay well congratulations early thank
you and I I hope it the last one I had
was eight days late and so I'm like
really pray that we don't go that long
so um thank you very much my name is
Michelle Merritt I'm the president at
new futures um my colleague Emma savini
testified during the hearing and I did
want to bring up an issue um that new
Futures had been working on it's
actually a legacy issue that was sort of
brought back up um in the context of
reviewing this bill in 2016 um when we
were in the height of the opiate
epidemic there was a bill very similar
to this that was put forward that um had
some unintended consequences when it
came to uh parental substance misuse and
including it in the definition of
neglect um we did a lot of work on this
and ultimately settled in the area of
creating a rebuttable presumption of
harm um that still exists within the
statute so by way of refresher and um I
know that Dartmouth as well as many
OBGYNs and others had concerns around
this provision as well I've taken a look
at what I think is the amended language
and I we still have concerns about this
um
so essentially what it boils down to is
we never want to create a situation in
which we are deterring individuals with
substance use disorder from obtaining
prenatal
care um how we are reading this language
because it's included in the definition
is that it would subject objn as well as
social workers and others to report
women who have children at home who are
also pregnant for abuse and
neglect the unintended consequence of
that is that they may not receive the
care that they want out of fear that
their children are going to be taken
away it is our opinion that there is
nothing within the rebuttable
presumption of harm that we're trying to
figure out exactly what it is that is
trying to be addressed here by including
these additional definitions and the
definition of
neglect yes so if I may M chair so it
specifically States when the child is
born M okay so I don't think that that
affects the children at home
but I do think that a parent that is
having issues with substance misuse
there is always a danger to that child
like I said in that in the committee
that anytime there are drugs around you
run the risk of a child
dying I don't I and I you know I I mean
I just listened to a podcast of that
very same thing where the state was
called on this family several times and
that child was never removed and that
child's dead because it got into its
parents' drugs so I I don't think it's
fair I I don't think this is going to
stop anyone from going to prenatal I I
just don't see that happening this is
when the child is born
and I I think it's more important that
we protect all those
children yep so hi for the record uh um
senior director of government relations
at Dartmouth health so I am I am reading
this with both my OBS in mind and our
general counsel and our general counsel
has to have um reviews policies and
procedures that our OB departments have
to use and so I'm I have their lens in
mind I'm an attorney as well and when I
look at this um I am
seeing uh qu yes one's born right that
that would trigger the referral itself
but when I am looking if you look
further down and I'm on page I don't
think I'm on the amendment but I'm on
page five lines
31 and um when it's it specifically says
unless uh the exposure is due to having
been prescribed so what if a what if a
mom comes to us and her third trimester
and she be Suboxone or borine but what
happens um for a mom who comes and she
and it's just the third trimester but
for the first two trimesters she was
using illicit
substances if I'm if I'm an when they're
born this has nothing to do during their
trimester right but if I'm an OB
provider our general counsel was going
to have to say in that one circumstance
even though the child was born and mom
was prescribed those medications in the
third
trimester that was not protected in the
first trimester or the second trimester
so this would trigger a a referral and
that's where that's where this provision
is very gray and really subject to
interpretation in our my conservative
General Council my with conservative Len
is is going to say this a referral needs
to go forward but it states right in the
language that they are monitored by a
licensed healthc care provider when on
this and that's what would it would be
if they even if it came to the third
trimester they would be monitored by a
health care Prof professional who is
giving them the Suboxone in that one
scenario though they weren't monitored
for the first two trimester but the
child wasn't born it's once they AR the
child is born right and as long as
they're in that third trimester and
they're having that I I'm never going to
change from this language and and I love
you guys you know that but um I I'm just
not because I think CH children deserve
the right to be protected also so I
think if the legislative intent is to
make sure that there's a a smaller
window I I I'm know Michelle would be
happy to work on that I would be happy
to work on that I hear the intent but I
as I'm reading the language there's some
gray area and I'm just concerned that I
do think that there I do know that there
will be women who are afraid to receive
prenatal care that they need so I'm
going to respectfully disagree with you
because I think the language is quite
clear go ahead thank you thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um so two may ask two question course um
would you be able to email us some
suggested um we we could work on that um
to try to tighten it up and make it more
narrowly tailored I'm I'm with
representative rice um because um I
think that we need to protect innocent
children but I also wanted to bring up a
point that it's also an opportunity when
the child is born for the mother to get
support that she might not have had
before and so that is this provides that
and you know um the
goal our goal is to keep families intact
so providing support to the mother so
she can keep that baby instead of you
know God knows what so the baby lives
yeah you're singing our song you're
singing our song We're not in
disagreement with any of this it's truly
a matter of how this is phrased and the
unintended consequences that will come
up of women not receiving prenatal care
for really high-risk pregnancies when
they we want to encourage them to go and
receive care um we also have Federal
requirements so any baby bornn in the
state of New Hampshire right now that is
exposed to substances has to have a safe
plan of care as it is right now those
resources are being coordinated the
hospital is responsible for making sure
that that occurs um and there also are
ways in which if a provider has concern
it's sort of it's substance use plus is
the standard if if there is evidence of
substance use plus any concern at all
that a child is at risk for not having
appropriate supervision that there may
be drugs that are in the home home that
are not being put away they are not
having stable housing there are things
in place right now that allow for DCF to
get involved the question that we have
is how really why is this section
necessary above and beyond what already
exists in statute that provides that
level of assurance um given the work
that was done in 2016 and again in 2021
where we address this issue fairly
comprehensively
um I do have the legislative history
because we worked on that um we actually
worked on it with you representative
rice um Senator long and you
representative deimon at the time so it
has this is something that we have
talked about about the negative
consequences that are possible for
babies being born in tents and moms not
receiving prenatal care and that is a
new Futures and Dartmouth are in
agreement that is something that we want
to avoid and we do have concern with how
the language is framed here that that
may be an unintended consequence if we
don't tighten it up well I would be
really interested to hear what your um
and we'll be meeting again that first
Monday in March what the but before then
if you could send us I will not be here
hope yes you will not be here but um but
we worked with Dr Roy if I am I'm gonna
be bringing in a week old baby with me
Dr Roy ex I know yeah Dr Roy extensively
from Dartmouth worked on this you know
in this language because this really is
the definitions of what child abuse and
neglect looks like and once again we
don't want to make exceptions when we're
just defining this now what happens
after what happens with communication
with mothers and stuff is very very
import important now we did have some
trauma informed language that we kind of
switch that up to that we have um and we
have no issue with any other part or
section of what is trying to be
accomplished here well in this and in
this state we want to be um we we can't
leave this out we do have you know
issues in this state that this is going
to be really important as far as how
this goes right now um I actually think
because we have this about monitoring
you know unless it's monitored by a
licensed healthcare provider which by
the way in statutes after talking to a
federal judge would include if they if
they weren't there the first couple
months but then came in you know at the
last part of their pregnancy because in
that point we can't Define and by the
way the original I think Bill that came
out said in utero and we would never put
that in there because that's not the
definition that's not the children that
we're defining at that point um but
certainly that's more about the mother
until they're born so as long as even if
they've come in like within two weeks
before they give birth they still at
that point are now under care if
anything I would think looking at this
um in in talking to women who have been
in high atrisk situations knowing that
if they have a Prov provider that's
caring for them that helps to protect
them I think this language actually
would be more of a seat belt for them
wanting to get healthc care provider um
input or at least talking to them
because at that point then they're under
that care yeah you just need to have you
have to understand that healthc care
providers have work for a healthcare
institution that that have a general
counsel that's going to read this
language with a strict with a really
strict legal lens and this does happen
and even with the rebuttable presumption
language that we've done extensive
amount of work on there are still
concerns and I am I'm not asking to walk
back the rebuttable presumption language
but I'm just saying that even today with
that rebuttable presumption language our
providers are being placed between their
patients whom they want to care for and
do it really holistically and
appropriately and general counsel who
are attorneys that um have to look at
the language of the law only the
language of the law um I also just want
to knowe Dr Roy did not work with our
office to on this language so the
legislative history that that we have in
in government relations is not something
that Dr Roy knows about I don't know Dr
Roy it's my understanding that she
actually works at Elliott which is a
partner program in our child and safety
protection program so would love to meet
her but I um that was not done through
our office and um there were other folks
within Dartmouth that were part of the
group that articulated concern including
their Pediatric
department so um yeah it is something
that we remain concerned about great and
we would love so I know that when you
came to the hearing before we asked for
new language that would be helpful so we
would really because we would like um
obviously we have some high concerns too
so if you could get that language to us
in the next two weeks that would be
fantastic let's work on that maybe
there's a way to contemplate the safe
plan of care and thread the needle in
this bill I don't know we can look we
can look at it yeah and it would be
helpful to understand from our
perspective where the rebuttable
presumption of harm language that's in
there that covers some of these
situations is falling short um because
it's something that we're not really
making that connection of why it's
absolutely necessary that it's repeated
twice in here and where there's failures
and folks falling through the gaps um
because we would certainly want to
tighten that up but we just we work with
the recovery Community all the time we
don't have an understanding or an
appreciation for where that it actually
is occurring what is the actual problem
that we're trying solve by adding this
language in here and where the
rebuttable presumption is falling
[Music]
short hi thank you and thank you for
taking my question and maybe this is
something that we might have um need
help with um in researching but do you
um have any um anything that you can
email to us or um maybe you know this
that would um let us know the percentage
of women with with substance use
disorders who are using while pregnant
who seek uh prenatal care period and is
there any data that shows a correlation
in states where they have added this
into their child abuse language in law
um a decrease in the amount of prenatal
care for women in that population do you
know of anything yeah I'd have to look
back some of it might be a little bit
stale but I do recall when we were
working on this in 2016 that the data in
that area was fairly compelling that
there was a deterrent in women receiving
pratal care because they were scared um
yeah but after legislation is what
you're talking about in States that had
similar Provisions that what their
impact was and again to Courtney's Point
um it it has been the case and we've
been navigating this for a while there's
a presumption to theability issues of
like obviously when in doubt report and
in some cases even when it's not
necessary um and that also has been a
factor that we have been actively trying
to work with the recovery community and
providers and others to try to say you
don't have to report every single
instant where Mom comes in pregnant and
has an active substance use disorder um
but it's still occurs and I have concern
that the language as drafted is just
going to make that situation worse but I
think I do have some information and
data back from when we originally worked
on this in 2016 that I can pull for you
thank you we did hear testimony that day
that there is already uh worry and
concern amongst people who are using so
what how does that change then like if
they're already concerned I'm yeah
that's my point no yeah it's a it's a
valid point there is some concern
providers are actively being educated
like I know Dartmouth has done a lot of
work internally to try to sway people um
of their practices hospitals have
internal practices that they have been
actively working with the Department to
try to receive education so that they're
doing the right thing but this is an
added layer of confusion that when we're
trying to do that already right now it's
not going to make the situation any
better okay nobody else has questions we
appreciate your time and I'd love to see
that language I was looking for it after
our last after you were here last time
yeah that would be great thank
you um
we you guys have time for Lista masota
okay okay are you okay
on okay I just real quick wanted to
clarify the the background of this um
because again this bill has been out
there since the fall of
2023 um with this substance exposed
newborn language in there Dr Roy was at
the Elliott at that time she is a
pediatric abuse specialist not not
maternal Health but we did talk to her
about it she is actually at Dartmouth
Hitchcock now though she's been
installed for month and a half or so as
the new cap examiner there but um
regardless I think when this language
was drafted and we did not pull in the
maternal Health folks which we certainly
should have and would love to see
additional language it was with a lot of
research as to best practice around this
issue a lot of states have addressed
this issue in statute and was adopting
this best practice of substance exposure
plus which was just mentioned that's
what this language is it's the exposure
at Birth with a carve out for
appropriate Medical Care Plus additional
indicators of harm just as you were
saying representative rice because the
concern is not just the exposure we do
not want every mother whose infant has
an exposure at Birth could even just be
the marijuana we don't want those calls
the purpose of this language was to
permit women who have are under
treatment for Methadone or whatever but
to also require something more and it is
our understanding and again if there's
different language out there we'd love
to see it um it shouldn't just be
exposure it's exposure plus but it is
that plus that is scary because we have
also seen infant deaths fentanyl
exposure deaths safe sleep deaths which
increase exponentially when there's
substance use in the home and that is
what we are trying to void um the
rebuttable presumption language I think
is different it does not directly
address substance exposed newborns in
the same way that this language does so
that's why we we weren't looking at them
as duplicative or or conflicting in any
way um we they're separate so I just
want to give you guys the background
certainly if there's other language out
there but we were really trying to put
in
clearly this best practi standard of
exposure plus which was not in our
statute
before I think that uh concludes our
subcommittee meeting for today and it
certainly gave us a Full Slate of what
to talk about this next time so we do
look forward to having that language
obviously not from you and good luck
with your delivery um but uh we would
like to have that as soon as possible
just so that we can look at that and get
that going we had mentioned a couple
times we were looking for that and had
not seen it in the emails yet so we're
really um looking forward to that so we
can then talk to the people who are on
the ground who are doing this kind of
work to make sure that that's something
that works for them too
yes so this is the amendment that if you
you can approach um this is the
amendment for uh for that bill that I
think no it is not a replace all no
you'll see the
sections so yeah please feel free to
take
that and uh we look forward to hearing
from you thank you everyone for being
here today it's very important bill and
um thank you members of the committee
for being here thank
you it's that yes uh so the next Monday
I think that we can meet because we have
vacation and President's day is March
the 3D right is that Monday is that the
3rd or
4th no the first Monday in March it's
the 3 so the 3D at 11 does that work for
everyone Y and hopefully at that point
we will have had some language and uh
we'll be talking about that because they
are looking to exact this bill on March
4th um and I certainly do not want to
upend this entire work um for uh one
section want to make sure we have that
under wraps too okay thanks